so this is chlorine it's 99.5% and this
is probably the only element that I'm
quite happy to leave inside the
container so chlorine is quite an
abundant element it's found a lot in
seawater for example and it's found in
common salt like sodium chloride
chlorine gas itself the element is CL 2
is a greenish gas it was used widely in
the First World War as a warfare agent
whole regiments of chemistry students
were recruited to go out onto the front
to let off this gas which went across
the battlefields when the wind was
blowing in the right direction if it's
damp like it was on the battlefields
it's very reactive so it started
reacting with the metal on the soldiers
battles and so on making a green and so
on now it's actually a very very
reactive and very very toxic element and
I remember doing the photolysis
experiment with this and hydrogen a few
years ago and we had to prepare an
intimate mixture of hydrogen and
chlorine gases and then photolyze them
with a lamp but the slightest whiff of
chlorine and and I just feel physically
sick it's actually a good reaction to
have de chlorine because like the label
says it's actually quite toxic both me
and the environment so it's a bit like
the Ron sale of the chemical world it
does exactly what it says on the tin
chlorine is now widely used in the
plastics industry to make PVC the
plastic that's used for covering flex
metal on all sorts of electrical
equipment I'm sure I've got some here
for example this is PVC coated cable
here and it's also used for bleaching
and in
about thirty years ago or so when my
children were young in the days before
disposable nappies people reused cloth
nappies and this needed to be bleached
with chlorine and so they use powders
like this one here which contained
chlorine compounds which mixed with
water would release chlorine itself so
that you could react chlorine and bleach
the nappies and make them nice and clean
but without having to use liquid
chlorine in its normal form